je dois frapper comme une pierre,
dur comme une pierre de marbre,
je suis fait de chair de viande, je suis
né un matin à la pause, un
jour, j'ai attrapé mon fardeau et je suis parti,
je mesurais six pieds, je pesais 44 livres,
j'ai eu un  le talon me démange et je vise à me
déplacer je dois frapper comme un rocher et un cœur
comme une pierre de marbre
je suis fait de viande j'ai une chanson dans mon
pauvre bras droit
maintenant je suis gros dans le mal mais je ne veux pas dire non
mal, je suis fait de viande et je suis
gros comme l'acier, je dois courir autour de l'âme
et un moteur guérit nos mots et nos promenades
de ville en ville, aucun homme ne peut
m'épauler, j'ai une tête comme un  un
rocher et un cœur comme une pierre à pompons,
je suis un pot fait de viande, j'ai du sel dans ma
piscine en ce moment,
je suis grand au lit mais je ne veux pas faire
de mal, je suis fait de viande et je suis  gros
comme l'acier, je dois courir autour de l'âme et un
talon qui démange, je parle et je divague de
ville en ville, aucun homme ne peut
m'épauler, je dois frapper comme un
rocher
et un cœur comme une pierre de bouteille,
je dois frapper comme  un rocher
et
des pierres
il y a une vieille ballade d'iris appelée
male malone
dans la
belle ville de Dublin
où sont les filles
et elle
brandit une brouette
à travers les rues
larges et étroites
cristal
elle était poissonnière et le destin n'était pas
étonnant
car son père et sa mère
étaient
aussi poissonniers
et  ils manient
et les muscles
sont
vivants
et elle est morte
d'une fièvre
dont personne ne
pouvait la soulager
et c'était
la fin de la
douce Molly
Malone
maintenant son fantôme
fait rouler son baril
à travers
les rues
et les muscles
sont vivants
Coco
et les muscles
sont
vivants
alors
maintenant voici une chanson sur
deux des personnes les plus dangereuses au
monde
c'est un homme et une femme
et les noms de frankie et johnny
maintenant frankie et johnny
étaient amants
oh mon dieu comment ils pouvaient aimer
veulent juste être fidèles l'un à l'autre
aussi vrai que les étoiles au-dessus
de lui  C'était son homme
mais il l'a
fait
maintenant Frankie, elle était une bonne femme
comme tout le monde sait qu'elle a
payé cent dollars
pour chaque costume de vêtements de Johnny,
elle aimait cet homme
mais il lui a
tout fait
maintenant, c'était un meurtre au premier degré,
c'était un meurtre au premier degré.  Troisième
Frankie, elle a simplement laissé tomber un homme
comme un chasseur laisse tomber un oiseau, elle a tué
cet homme
mais il
lui a bien fait du mal
la première fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il a
chancelé
la prochaine fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il est tombé la
dernière fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, oh mon Dieu, il y
avait un nouveau  visage d'homme en enfer, elle a
tué cet homme,
Dieu sait que tu as mal fait,
puis Frankie est descendue à Broadway
aussi loin qu'elle pouvait voir,
tout ce qu'elle pouvait entendre était un arc à deux cordes
qui jouait là-bas, oh mon dieu
et cette histoire n'a pas de fin,
cette histoire ne fait que continuer  pour montrer qu'il
n'y a rien de bon chez certains hommes, ils vous feront
du mal,
tout comme cela montre que vous êtes né,
voici une chanson sur les deux personnes les plus
dangereuses au monde,
un homme et une femme, et les noms
sont Frankie Johnny
maintenant
Frankie et Johnny
étaient amoureux,
oh mon Dieu, comment pouvaient-ils aimer, ils
voulaient juste être fidèles l'un à l'autre,
aussi vrais que les étoiles au-dessus,
il était son homme,
elle était une bonne femme,
comme tout le monde le sait,
elle a payé cent dollars
pour chaque costume de Johnny.
j'ai adoré cet homme
mais il l'a fait
maintenant ce n'était pas un meurtre au premier degré ce
n'était pas un meurtre au troisième
frankie elle a simplement laissé tomber un homme comme un
chasseur laisse tomber un oiseau elle a tué cet homme
parce qu'il a bien fait une erreur
la première fois qu'elle a tiré  lui, il a
chancelé
la prochaine fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il est tombé
la dernière fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, oh mon Dieu, il
y avait le visage d'un nouvel homme en enfer, elle a
tué cet homme
parce qu'il l'avait mal fait,
puis Frankie est descendue à Broadway
aussi loin qu'elle pouvait voir
tout ce qu'elle pouvait  J'entends qu'un arc à deux cordes
jouait là-bas, oh mon Dieu, dans
toute la ville, le
pauvre John est mort,
maintenant cette histoire n'a pas de morale
et cette histoire n'a pas de fin.
Cette histoire ne fait que montrer qu'il
n'y a rien de bon chez certains hommes.  je vais te faire
du mal,
tout aussi sûr que
c'est une chanson d'amour qui s'appelle
tu sais bébé ce que je veux de toi
tu sais bébé ce que je
veux de toi
un très gros bisou
tu sais bébé
ce que je veux de toi
c'est un câlin
un très gros câlin
maintenant je  je ne serai pas
trop impatient
j'attendrai
que tu décides
bébé et quand tu auras fini de décider
maintenant laisse ta conscience être ton dieu tu
sais bébé ce que je veux de toi
c'est
maintenant je ne serai pas
trop impatient
j'attendrai
que tu décides
bébé et quand tu auras fini de décider
maintenant laisse ta conscience être ton dieu
est
siree
oui oui oui siree eh
bien voici un vieux favori je pense que tu
connais cette chanson elle s'appelle le
blues de l'infirmerie de Saint James
elle était là
dans un coin
de la place
ils  nous servions
des boissons comme d'habitude
et la foule habituelle était là
à ma gauche Big Joe Mckenna
et ses yeux étaient rouges injectés de sang,
il a tourné son visage vers les gens,
ce sont les mêmes mots qu'il a prononcés
alors que j'étais à l'infirmerie Saint James,
j'ai vu mon bébé là-bas
j'ai tendu une longue et longue table blanche
si douce, fraîche et juste,
laisse-la partir, laisse-la
partir, que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit, elle
peut parcourir ce vaste monde,
elle ne trouvera jamais un homme plus doux que moi
quand je mourrai,
s'il te plaît, enterre-moi
et mon  haut, stable,
mets une pièce d'or de 20 sur ma chaîne de montre,
tu sais que je suis mort, je ferais
mieux d'y aller,
laisse-la partir, que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit,
elle peut parcourir ce
monde entier,
elle ne trouvera jamais un homme plus doux que moi,
je veux  six tireurs de merde pour être mon pauvre
porteur
trois jolies femmes
pour chanter une chanson
mettre une camionnette de jazz sur le chariot de mon cœur
et soulever l'enfer pendant que je me promène
laisse-la partir laisse-la partir que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit,
elle peut fouiller ce vaste monde
plus
elle ne trouvera jamais d'homme plus doux que moi
maintenant les gens que vous avez entendu mon histoire
maintenant que vous avez entendu ma chanson
si quelqu'un vous demande,
dites-lui que j'ai entendu dire que c'est
mieux qu'elle
aille, que Dieu la bénisse
partout  elle peut peut-être
parcourir le monde entier,
elle ne trouvera jamais
un homme plus doux
que
moi